en este tercer vídeo quiero ver más
ejemplos de problemas de funciones
además me gustaría presentarte una idea
bonita mira ya vimos dos formas en las
cuales podemos definir funciones una es
a través de una igualdad con una
expresión algebraica y la otra es a
partir de casos o sea esto era más o
menos como cuando decíamos que la
función valía algo si x era impar y
valía otra cosa si x era par pero hay
una tercera forma en la cual podemos
definir una función y es a partir de una
gráfica déjame pasar aquí abajo
y para esta idea de la gráfica vamos a
necesitar un par de ejes aquí los tengo
dibujados ahí están los ejes tenemos un
eje horizontal y un eje vertical y la
idea es que aquí en esta gráfica vamos a
pintar un puntito si a un cierto valor
en el eje x estoy aquí es el eje x le
corresponde un cierto valor
efe de x valor f de x entonces déjame
poner algunos puntitos aquí y ahorita
vemos específicamente a qué me refiero
voy a poner un punto aquí arriba en
altura 2 aquí en el -5 a altura 2 en el
-4 altura menos 1 también menos 1 lo voy
a marcar un poco más
y también va a ser mismo
estoy marcando algunos puntos y estos
puntos nos van a indicar el valor de la
función entonces voy a poner unos
cuantos más ya casi terminó va a poner
nada más este de acá
ok entonces además de esos puntos déjame
déjame trazar algunas líneas que los
unan este vaya aquí para cada estos
quedan unidos así esto así esto va para
acá y luego esto va a aparcar
más o menos bueno este puntito déjame
ponerlo un poco más abajo está ok
entonces aquí tenemos una gráfica y
puedes decir oye esa gráfica se ve como
muy chistosa y muy rara y cuando siguen
efectos y se ve chistosa y rara pero la
cosa es que esta gráfica nos permite
definir una función de la siguiente
manera si tomamos un cierto valor de x
que esté entre menos 5 y 5 esta línea
nos va a decir cuánto es fx observando
la altura por ejemplo si estamos aquí en
el -5 si tomamos el valor menos 5
entonces la función evaluada en el -5 va
a ser igual a 2 porque aquí está a la
altura 2 vale
déjame hacer algunos otros por ejemplo
qué pasa con cero acuse en cero la línea
esta altura cero entonces
efe de cero efe de cero
es igual a 0 de manera similar
efe de 1 es igual a menos 1 por aquí
está el 1 y este al menos 1 f1 es igual
a menos 1 creo que se ve la idea verdad
básicamente tomamos un punto y nos vamos
a la línea para ver el valor de la
función bueno entonces esta es una forma
gráfica de definir una función y a
partir de esta función y otras más vamos
a resolver algunos ejemplos pensemos que
además de esta función efe también nos
dan una función de x definida así como
gdx es igual a efe de x elevado al
cuadrado para que no sea confuso voy a
poner aquí un paréntesis es primero
encontrar fx y luego elevar eso al
cuadrado y además tenemos que restar fx
entonces esta es la definición de g y
tenemos una tercera función que se llama
hdx y está definida como 3 menos
muy bien entonces teniendo estas tres
funciones
imagínate que nos piden determinar le
voy a poner h de g
de menos 1 como le haríamos para
determinar esto pues es la misma idea
que en los vídeos anteriores primero
determinamos cuánto es gd menos 1
entonces vamos a hacer g de menos uno
por aquí abajito entonces g de menos uno
gm uno es igual a pues simplemente este
menos uno lo sustituimos en cada
aparición de x entonces este menos uno
aquí diría menos uno nos quedaría efe de
menos uno esto elevado al cuadrado
- efe - 1
y ahora tenemos que ver cuánto es f1
pero para saber quiénes efe de -1
tenemos que ir a la gráfica entonces por
aquí está el -1 y efe de menos uno es
igual a uno vale efe de menos uno es
igual a uno de esta forma este efe de
menos uno es igual a un 1 nos queda 1 al
cuadrado es también es un 1 que da 1 al
cuadrado menos 1 y estoy aquí es igual a
0 vale entonces xerez menos 1 es igual a
0 y ahora podemos sustituir este valor
aquí arriba para ver cuánto es h de gm 1
entonces estoy aquí h de gm
uno sería igual a h de cero y h de cero
usando esta definición la de hdx h de
cero es igual a 30 y eso es igual a 3
muy bien entonces ya tenemos que deje de
menos 1 es igual a 3 vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo pero antes un consejo si si te
atrás un poquito en estos problemas te
recomiendo volver a ver el vídeo pero
para usarlo en el momento en el
yo escribo el ejercicio eso te va a
permitir intentarlo por tu cuenta y ya
después puedes ponerle reproducir para
ver si hicimos lo mismo y si obtuvimos
el mismo resultado bueno entonces vamos
a hacer otro ejemplo voy a volver a
utilizar esta función
efe para no graficar este otra función
pero déjame cambiar las funciones g y h
bueno de hecho nada más voy a poner una
función entonces imagínate que ahora nos
dicen que eje x éste ya es otro problema
g de x es igual
es igual a efe de x al cuadrado
más le voy a poner f de x + 2 vale
entonces esto de aquí es gd x y ahora lo
que nos piden determinar es el valor de
g de menos 2 vamos a poner el eje de
menos 2 muy bien entonces cómo le
hacemos pues misma idea sustituimos
todas las x que tenemos aquí por menos 2
entonces tendríamos efe de menos 2 al
cuadrado más
efe de menos dos más dos simplemente
simplificamos un poco estas expresiones
nos queda igual a efe de 4
más efe de 0 y recuerda para obtener los
valores de f lo que tenemos que hacer es
consultar esta gráfica de acá entonces
vamos a ver cuánto es
efe de 4 entonces tenemos 1234 por aquí
está el 4 y la altura a la cual estamos
en 4 es 2 entonces efe de 4 es igual a 2
y efe de 0 bueno se fue de 0 0 verdad
aquí está efe 0 es igual a 0
entonces nos quedaría igual a 2 + 0 y
por lo tanto g de menos 2 es igual a 2
muy bien entonces como ves estos
problemas están realmente interesantes
algo que te recomiendo es que sigas
jugando con algunos ejemplos
tú inventa de tus propios problemas e
intenta evaluar las funciones en ciertos
valores y eso te va a ayudar muchísimo
para practicar de hecho otra cosa que
estaría interesante es ver cómo es la
gráfica de esta función g
o sea que esta función g intentar
meterla ahí al plano bueno a aquí a los
ejes entonces bueno quieres puedes
prestar acerca de eso a lo mejor después
lo hagamos en otro vídeo ahorita ahorita
creo que ya no tengo tanto tiempo para
intentar otro ejemplo así que lo
dejaremos para el siguiente vídeo pero
la idea es seguir haciendo varios
ejercicios de funciones para que te
acostumbres a esta idea y veas que es
muy muy versátil y que tiene muchas
aplicaciones bueno nos vemos hasta la
próxima y diviértete